you would know more than i am but this
guy's tim and his brother i i'm not that
close with them i'm friendly with them
i'm friends with them but i'm not that
close like i if you told me that they
were worth over 150 million dollars i
wouldn't be surprised and they still act
like they're poor
in kind of a funny way which i enjoy and
they're
they're super humble and they're like
super hard
still and they invest in everything
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to
today we're gonna answer a bunch of
questions uh but did you see
trunks tweet about the guy selling the
card
no what is it trung tweeted out this
video that he found from
probably the 90s or probably from the
2000s early 2000s
and it's a guy uh who's got like who's
like trying to sell you on his like
business card that's a big square and
you open it up and it's a pop-out and
he's just really intense
but the video got it's funny you haven't
seen this no
oh well this won't be any good then but
the video got like half a million views
and people are making websites uh about
the tweet or about the video based off
his tweet it was just funny
do you see half a million views now or
like he tweeted something that already
had half a million views
no it did now oh wow trung is a master
of uh finding great content that guy is
really good
i have this like apprentice who's
working with me chris for uh content
he's been the red head guy yeah yeah
he's like kind of like shadowing me and
he helps me produce my content and
and he's learning as he goes and um
i told him i was like you know success
is being trung
so like that's the level that's the top
bar um
that's that's what you need to measure
against here's five examples of like
awesome things he's done
and so he called trung he was like
what's your secret what's your process
basically drug was like oh you know like
i
kind of browse the internet a lot and
you know there's no way you can you know
it's like
asking michael jordan how do you jump so
high type of thing like it's not
it's not easy to describe how you do the
thing that doesn't feel like a real
process for you you know you're just
doing it native
intuitively he's a machine one time i
called him at 11 o'clock his time he's
in vancouver and he was at the park
playing with his son
and i was like trung like i'm not trying
to like get on you because i'm not your
boss but like don't you have work to do
like and he was like bro i bro i got up
at 5 am and i already wrote
tomorrow's email already i was like all
right sounds good
okay it's a machine so i didn't see this
video is it worth talking about given
that i didn't see it or what
it's too long to go through basically
okay people and myself
let's go to twitter after this and let's
go to trung t
fan i think is his uh handle and
look at his thing and he the funniest
thing that he's done lately is he owns
onlyfans.com
dude that slayed me it was so funny so
he has only fans but he spells fans
p-h-a-n
like his last name and it's just a
network for only people with last name
fan
and i just thought that's so funny
for some reason it's funnier than when i
think that he came up with it
yeah now we don't like it so much
all right today we're gonna answer
questions i uh we got
uh it looks like we got like six pages
of text questions so like
dozens and dozens of text questions and
then we got a few dozen
uh audio questions like people calling
in but uh some of the text questions
were good i'm gonna start off
um i'm gonna start i'm gonna read a few
that i think are cool
let's do the first one this guy's name
is uh johnny volcky asks
what are you both personally investing
in right now by the way do you know
johnny volk do you know who this is
he i talked to him on twitter and he's
joe spicer's buddy
he lives out here in the bay area he
lives like you know 15 minutes away from
me
he super successful e-commerce guy been
an e-com for 10 years sold his company
recently like
i don't know a month ago or something
for tens of millions of dollars and
he's a big investor in my rolling fund
and several other rolling funds and
uh really like ultra nice guy so this
guy's super legit so he's asking
what are you both personally investing
in so you want to go first i think you
uh yeah i think you're interested your
answer is probably more interesting i'll
go first so
right now the bulk of my liquid net
worth
is in publicly traded companies um i
own a bunch of hubspot right now i own a
bunch of airbnb
besides that i don't own anything else
above
50 000 uh it's all in um
so you're super concentrated in those
two companies basically
yeah but then i have more money in the s
p 500
so like the total stock market index um
i have i'm going to invest around 250 to
500 000
uh in the next probably 18 months in
startups
uh i had i owned six figures worth of uh
into a variety of real estate funds
including sweaty startup nick hoover
um and then i own um my house
uh and i'm in the process of buying
multi-family properties
so i would say i have like if you just
broke it out you're like
perce you know roughly you're like okay
70 is in
the stock market really in the two
companies you know where my wife works
and when i work something like that no i
i own way more just sp500 than i do
hubspot and airbnb um but i would say
that uh
ninety percent of my net worth is in
the s p 500 yeah oh wow okay so just
like
low low low cost index fund basically
vanguard fund
simple stuff and then my goal was to
invest somewhere around
one to three percent of my net worth
over a period of time into angel
investments
gotcha uh cool and then some real estate
mixed in real estate being you know the
house you live in
and some other you know projects other
people are doing you're not currently
buying and like owning real estate at
the moment uh i'm going
i owe my house but i'm gonna i want to
buy 16 units i also have
i mean i'll say like half a million
dollars in cash just sitting in a
checking account
um which i think is too much money but
uh i
when i bought my car i just paid cash
out of there and then i um
i owned six figures of uh bitcoin and
ethereum of which i
owned most of that bitcoin from 2013 and
i just bought like 75 000
worth of ethereum like a few days ago
because you and a few others told me it
was interesting
nice uh by the way we got some criticism
constructive criticism i would say
which was like oh the last few episodes
uh feel like you know rich guy's talking
about
you know ways to make a bunch of money
which um honestly
good description for the podcast but but
i get what the person's saying because
they're like a fan
and they're like that's me raising my
hand because i think
i basically was like oh this [__] thing
is cool and it sounds like a total ponzi
scheme and so people are like
what are you or we're talking about like
jack selling like a nft for like 70
million dollars so it just sounds like a
little bit crazy
um so i think you know although i think
your answer is great because i like
knowing how people invest their money i
think it's most people are very closely
guarded with that info people don't tell
you what the hell they're doing
so you're kind of on your own to figure
stuff out and
you don't really have any data points
triangulate because all the wealthy
people don't want to talk about what
they're doing with their wealth unless
it's with other really wealthy people
and so i think it's great you said that
but i'm also as you were saying it that
was just ringing in my head
of like some guy being like why are you
guys just talking about money but it's
like well that's also the theme of the
podcast in a way
and that was also the question i'm
trying to answer it truthfully
but also when we started this podcast
when you started this podcast
a year and a half ago or two years ago
it really wasn't
a bunch of rich guys talking about it
was a bunch of
hopefully soon to be rich guys talking
about stuff and we've been talking about
the same stuff the whole time
yeah oh you mean us yeah yeah yeah cause
yeah and also i put this out there in
the manifesto when i started this thing
which is
i i think it's unfortunate that
talking about money and how to make
money and what you do with money to make
how you make your money more uh earn you
more money i feel like it's unfortunate
that that's taboo
um to talk about like it's like kind of
like a it's like kind of like low class
or something to talk about because
look the reality is most people want
more money um
and people try to signal and say oh it
doesn't matter and all this stuff
i know a lot of people that want more
money most people in my life if i had
the option would you like more salary or
less
would you like more in your bank account
or less like the answer is more
and if if all the people who have money
are really guarded and don't talk about
it and don't want to seem
like they're bragging well what that
really does is it kind of like just
traps the information from others so
that's kind of like my overall view of
it
i know you're similar because i remember
being kind of stunned when we first
became friends
and you just facebook messaged me you're
like um like how much do you make
it's like whoa whoa bro like what's
going on here but i was like okay
you know ballsy question the reason why
that i actually dislike that view that's
or if someone criticizes you for about
money it's
because they are making the assumption
that because you have money or because
you don't you are somehow better or
worse
and in my opinion like i don't just
because you have money i
i that's you have no intrinsic value to
me like you either are
interesting or you are not interesting
and what makes you interesting to me is
that people
are just they try ambitious stuff and
they do neat stuff
oftentimes that's correlated with money
but it's not always like
i knew this lady who would do these
amazing art exhibits where she would
like paint gold phones
and like just do interesting stuff and i
was like wow that's super badass that's
so bold of you to try that she wasn't
wealthy at all but i thought it was so
cool
right so to me it's about uh just being
an interesting person i don't
really care if it's money related or not
but oftentimes it is
right for me i have like three or four
different uh life
games that i'm very interested in like
let's say right now i'm interested in
the fitness game
and i'm a total beginner i'm a white
belt at the fitness game
and so i have a trainer he's like more
like a black belt you know look at his
body look at his lifestyle he's
extremely healthy
and so i want to learn about the fitness
game i like learning about the happiness
game
how do you be like a happy person how do
you control your mood how do i master my
mood
i'm really interested in that i think
about that a lot talk to people about
that
then there's like the money game and
then there's like the making things that
people want game and i like all these
games
and i admire the people who have done
well in them and i'm better at some than
others where i'm like a total beginner
and in some i'm like you know a blue
belt or a purple belt where i've done
something but i'm
by no means at the end so anyways that's
a tangent but uh to answer john's
question
did you want to say something else about
that no i answered
to answer john's question uh i'm kind of
similar i i tweeted out my
like holdings a while back maybe i'll do
that again i need to go back and
recalculate
but i tend to hold about 10 of my
wealth in cash um i think cash is being
devalued
and i don't want to hold cash cash
doesn't earn you know cash sitting in
the bank is nice for a rainy day but it
doesn't
earn you more money um right the 0.001
i get from wells fargo or whoever is not
going to like help me
um i have a good size stock
you know basically i would say beyond
that it's almost like 50 50 of
public equities so stocks um and
you know crypto right now and uh i and
oh and then angel investing so
i'm angel investing currently through
the rolling fund four million a year but
that's not my money
uh that's mostly other people's money
and i get a carry on that i get a 20
carry of the profits so that's kind of
like investing but i'm not investing my
own money there
and i'm looking at real estate right now
but the problem with real estate for me
has always been
a i'm a beginner at that game and b um
i don't want to sign up for more work so
i'm looking for ways to get
real estate that's i directly own but
i don't have to do a ton of work and
those two are kind of uh
at opposites with each other i don't
invest in other people's real estate
funds right now
has your uh net worth or
like your total portfolio increase a
significant amount
since your deal because it seems like
you've like weren't very active before
and now you are very active and has that
helped you
it has increased because uh you know
the stock stock market's been doing
amazing last few years and
then with the deal you know like where
we
when we got bought the amazon stock
price was 18.50
amazon stock price today is 3 100. so
just while working there you know you
get
pretty significant gain in your holdings
there and because
we got bought like a large chunk of the
rsus were just in that one company so
that did well
uh crypto bitcoin has done extremely
well ethereum has done extremely well so
those have like
really worked and then um kind of like
the side hustle money
from podcast email newsletter
stuff like that um sponsorships that
sort of thing
has been really nice so that that's
that's actually picked up as well where
i wasn't doing that before
um so i'd say yeah but i would also say
um what really changed was my attitude
like i just started acting like a guy
who's got 100 million bucks
for better and for worse like i take
like bets that are
kind of too big for my bankroll
sometimes and that's a risk and i you
know might pay the price
but i sort of just started carrying
myself and acting like and basically
making decisions like what if i wasn't
worried about money what if i wasn't
worried about
you know going from a to b you know like
what if i just
knew that i'll get to b pretty much
regardless
how would i bet if that was the case and
so i started
making slightly larger bets and just
being more active uh whereas before
i was a little more conservative with
how i was investing which is
a huge difference in our philosophies
i'm way more conservative than you
way more conservative um and uh
i don't think i was telling to bray you
he was like because i told him i started
angel investment he was like who do you
think's gonna have a better portfolio
and i was like that's kind of
interesting and i
and the answer was like my answer to him
was i think my portfolio has a higher
chance of being pretty good
whereas sean's portfolio has a higher
chance of being
amazing or zero right uh
yeah i think that's true that's that's
definitely true i i guess like
the style of who you admire sort of
dictates what you do
what blueprint you create so like for
example i was really inspired by like
chris sacca's approach to how he
went from like you know he's like me
he's like a bit of a degenerate gambler
like he went you know
he took like his law school money and
then like
was tr day trading in the stock market
during the dot-com boom
wrote it up to like a 10 million like
took 25 000 and turned into like
10 million dollars and then went in the
whole four million dollars like that was
like a crazy degenerate gambling run
if you haven't heard me talking about my
bets in crypto and
you know i used to play poker like i'm
obviously i have a gambling problem also
right and so you know i have that risk
and reward profile
but then the other thing he did that i
thought i was pretty inspired by was he
you know he bet on somebody who he
believed in which was ev williams when
he started
what became twitter and then when he saw
that it was a winner
he like went all in in a way that most
people do not most people would have let
their 25k
check sit and been really excited and
fingers crossed i hope twitter becomes a
thing
he likes started he quit his job
basically started showing up at the
office every day being like
how are we going to make this thing grow
i want this thing to grow he went and
personally was fundraising for the
company even though he wasn't even a
part of the company
but he was out there pitching investors
to invest in twitter and then he ended
up
buying billions of dollars of twitter
stock uh before it went ipo and was
their i think first or second largest
shareholder at ipo and made
billions of dollars off of his twitter
holdings because he knew when you have a
winner
you got to go all in so what i've seen
is in technology
the winners get really really big and so
you kind of want to like play small bets
initially and then follow on really hard
and like when you see something that
actually works be really
bold uh in the way you approach it and
like hey if you strike out
i i kind of just think about it like
this i have a lot of faith in my skills
even if i went to zero today i think in
three years i'd be right back where i
want to be we're right back where i am
today
so like i don't feel like there's a huge
risk in terms of that but
anyways that's a little bit off topic
for one question all right let's do the
next one which was a question that i
actually have for you as well update us
on your rolling front fun
is it what you expected are you more or
less bullish on it
it is not what i expected in that
i didn't really think too much about it
before i started it to be honest which
is
you know i'm kind of impulsive i was
just like oh yeah that sounds like a
cool idea let me try it and see what
happens
but um i thought okay i already angel
invested
this is just going to be that with some
bigger checks or you know do a few more
deals
um but i would say now that i have to
deploy a million dollars a quarter
i actually have to carve out more time i
have to like consciously
go and invest in more companies so it's
it's more work than i thought
initially but uh i brought on romine i
brought on zach
ben helps me with it and so they do a
lot of the heavy lifting like for this
week's this
this year's yc batch you know zack
himself
referred in 22 of the companies he was
the number one i think
referrer into yc so he knew a bunch of
the yc companies before they even got in
we looked at those deals and then romine
basically and him went through every
single deal on an air table
vetted them made a list of the
interesting ones did meetings with them
and then brought the like most
interesting seven to me and were like
hey
we think these are the ones to do and so
that that like
i've been able to handle the additional
so it's more work than i thought
but i found really good people so that's
helpful who's this guy zach
zack is a young engineer he was a yc
founder himself
that company didn't work out he
currently uh so i met him because he
listens to the pod or i don't know
i don't know how he reached out but he's
like hey i heard you're thinking about
rolling fun i'd love to help
i just want to see a bunch of startups
and help a bunch of founders while i
think of my next thing
and uh and it just turns out he's just
like super well connected with the like
young founder community and so because
of that he's like referred a huge number
of people into yc and into on deck
and uh so he's got this really great
network and he's like able to like
see things earlier than most and so i
brought him into the fund and
and uh gave him a chance to hey now you
can have some upside in this
in this thing that's badass um and then
are you more bullish or less um
more yeah like the same i don't know i
was uh
i have a friend we have a mutual friend
sully who uh he wanted to get involved
in a business of mine
and he goes he said he texted me
something because i was like i was like
kind of i don't know
is this i don't want to give up equity
but like you know
um i think you're worth it
uh yeah so so basically he goes um
he goes look uh if i try i win and with
this i'll try
and uh and so i just loved it i was like
i'm just gonna learn a lot from this
guy's philosophy and business he just
has a
zero of the doubt and fear gene i think
that's
a new experience you would know more
than i am but this guy's silly it's him
and his brother i i'm not that close
with them i'm friendly with them
i'm friends with them but i'm not that
close like i if you told me that they
were worth over 150 million dollars i
wouldn't be surprised and they still act
like they're poor
in kind of a funny way which i enjoy and
they're
they're super humble and they're like
super hard working still
yeah and they invest in everything so
these guys are interesting they're two
brothers
yeah and silly's the same way actually
when i first met him i met him at
you you hosted the hustle con dinner at
my office this is how crazy the world
works this is like one of those
you can't connect the dots looking
forward you can only connect them when
you look back
you reached you cold emailed me saying
hey i want to host a dinner at your
office i didn't know
who the hell you were but you made a
strong pitch you said i'm going to have
all my speakers for my conference there
you can
you can you know meet all of them i was
like all right fair deal you can use my
office
at that dinner i meet suey sue's now my
best friend we've done
tons of deals together you know like
that wouldn't have happened if i hadn't
said yes to something that was kind of a
random thing
that's funny at that dinner i was like
dude this guy's amazing i've never heard
this guy's name before why don't people
in silicon valley know this guy
so i started googling him i find the
story that back in the day
he sold his he had this company that was
like building facebook apps and he sold
it for not a ton of money but like you
know
good for any normal person like two
million or three million dollars
between one and three million dollars
kind of what it sounded like and uh
and so and then what did he do with the
money he was like he had been building
on the facebook app platform so he had
been seeing that like his app was
growing really quickly and his app
wasn't a great business it was like
you know those like silly facebook apps
but he's like facebook is not silly
so he basically took a bunch of that
money and just pl he was like chris saka
he aggressively started buying up
facebook stock back then before it was
public
and then he did and he went to you know
in florida and he bought a bunch of real
estate
and i just thought wow this guy's really
like conducting himself i
at that time i was just kind of like i
thought of myself as an entrepreneur
but i acted more like an employee like i
wasn't playing the game to win i was
playing with these like
invisible handcuffs on me like i saw
these companies that were awesome i
didn't even go try to invest in them
and like when i saw that this guy when
he knew something was good he was like
how do i take all the money i have and
put it into this facebook thing i
believe in this
and simultaneously i'm gonna build my
next business now you know right away
and um and so i just really admired him
and i thought that that was a great
example
to follow he's a hustler um and i like
him a lot too let's go to the next
question which is
this is we'll answer this one quickly
what uh do you not
talk about or do we not have the chance
to talk about because low priority or
off topic that you wish you could talk
about for me it would be i love talking
about ufc
um i'm a big fitness guy so i love
sports i love
weightlifting and i like running and i
wish we could talk more about like uh
fitness stuff but i don't think it's on
topic and i'm not an expert on
expert on it yeah if i could do a
podcast shooting the [__] about
basketball or ufc that'd be awesome
uh but nobody cares what i think about
the nba or the ufc really
um so that's one and the other one i
think would just be
like i do kind of bring this in
sometimes but like
it takes up a lot more of my life than i
let show here on the pod which is like
on the pod i'm just talking about a
bunch of different
business ideas ways to make money in
reality i'm not just like doing that all
day
what i spend a lot more time thinking
about all day is like
my mindset so what is my life operating
philosophy
as i go about my day to be like the
happiest and best person i can be
and it's just kind of cheesy to talk
about and like no one kind of gives a
[__]
but like i give a [__] a lot about it
and i care a lot about it and i think a
lot about it but i don't really talk a
lot about it
i do i think about that stuff too yeah
but it is silly to talk about and it
could be embarrassing
particularly if you're still working
through stuff right
it's cool to talk about that i found
when you're in a small group of people
or you're in front of
if you're in person with some people
because you can get a sense for do they
give a [__] about this or not
right and it's also like kind of
personal uh on a podcast you you might
record that thing for an hour and you're
like i have no idea if even one person
is going to like
want to hear that or maybe they'll just
all turn it off
what's uh you guys are awesome at coming
up with incredible ideas
knowing how to execute them what would
it take for one of you to pull out of
twitch
or i guess in my case hubspot now
and pursue it full force that's actually
a great question and i have a i think is
a good answer
um go for it which it which is um first
of all
starting a company is really hard and
i've like
joked but i'm kind of serious i don't
know if i'm ever gonna do it again maybe
maybe not
right or at least like who knows what
i'm gonna do you know i thought it would
be cool just to like
retire and not work uh and we'll see if
that's cool
uh or not i don't know but um
i think that the answer far
or the answer should be but it is not
enough
of i just think this is cool so like why
are you doing this
because it's [__] cool and i think
that when i find something where it's
gonna be like oh this is badass this is
cool
like there's not like for me there's
often not like a
mission where it's like let's save the
world or let's it's like
ah it's just kind of badass it's just
awesome like right there's not there is
no logic other than this is
this is this is cool to me and
when i i found a few things that fit
that but
i'm still on a mission with hubspot and
i want to make it great and after that
then i'll pursue the next one i get
i don't like doing what i think sean you
do this a little bit and a lot of people
do i don't like starting lots of little
stuff
i prefer to dedicate my life to
something
and i'm very cautious about what i'm
willing to do that with because
you probably can only do that three to
four times in your life
and so um there's a few things but i'm
not i'm not finished with this chapter
yet and that's why i haven't done it
yeah that's a great answer i uh
similarly i basically was like all right
well what's this chapter of my life
about
and uh so when we got acquired i was
like well i want them to feel like
like glad that they did this acquisition
you know what i mean like i want them to
be like yeah that was worth it you know
and
for myself also i was like well cool
this is like a transition
let me like try this new thing let me
work at a big company never done that
before
let me have this like big cushy salary
type of thing like never had that before
i was kind of just eating [__] you know
like doing my own
my own startup like sleeping on kind of
an air mattress before
and so um so basically i was like all
right if my 20s were about
starting my own company and just trying
to figure out how to be an entrepreneur
what are my thirties going to be about
and i've decided it was two things i
said i want to you know
live a great life like with my family so
you know popped out two kids in the last
like 18 months
and so that that's actually like my
project is being a dad
and and having kids and spending time
and
just being there you know for that and
not trying to be like oh i must
because like you said now i know what it
takes to start a company i know how
all-consuming it is
so you've got to choose wisely
the second thing with choosing wisely is
my 30s are about
building a family and then it's building
a project i don't want to sell
which is basically like i totally agree
how do i
build my next thing same thing you said
this is something i want to do i'm not
doing it because it's the best business
idea or it's the hot opportunity or
whatever
but uh what it you know some the thing
that i just want to keep doing that i
don't want to get rid of i don't want to
sell it i just want to build it let it
compound for 30 40 years
and i love doing it and it's the thing
i'm uniquely good at doing
and i thought okay maybe i'll dabble in
some different things to figure out what
that is
and i feel like i found it which is like
ironic i found it where i wasn't looking
i started this podcast for a different
reason but i what i realized was oh i
really like this thing where i can be
kind of like
perpetually curious like i could just be
curious about the world
i can learn a bunch of [__] and then i
just share what i'm learning and i'm
kind of like a teacher
and uh through the podcast the email
newsletter through experiments like all
access pass
or i'm gonna launch some courses in the
future like i my lunch school
like basically i want to do things like
that something that lets me just be
really really curious and learn a bunch
of things and try a bunch of things and
then share as i go
because that's what i would do if i if i
let's just say if
work couldn't pay you money how would
you spend your time that's how i would
spend it
so might as well just do that as my work
and so that's what i think i'll do
next which won't look like a traditional
startup or company
and i agree with that uh i want to do
something that i never want to sell
um so i'm in the same boat uh the
question is directed towards you but
i'll give you my answer really quick
which is sean how do you balance side
hustles while performing at twitch
my answer to that and i've said it
before is
i don't ballot i don't do anything on
the side um
and frankly i have no idea how you do it
our good friend ramon is able to do it
really well
i get some people can do it i personally
can't do it and i don't even try and uh
i'm not ashamed about that
yeah yeah there's different ways to like
kind of organize your time like you see
this from elon musk or jack dorsey
running
two multi-billion dollar public
companies at once as ceo right kind of a
crazy thing that
kind of seemed impossible before and i
would say i do it
two ways one is i throw more hours at it
so like i don't take weekends off like i
work seven days a week
i don't work all day all seven days a
week but i
my weekend is just like my weekday
they're the same construction so all of
a sudden i got an
extra 16 hours on the weekend where i
can do things
same thing at night like i don't watch a
bunch of like tv i stopped watching
like you know nba games stuff like that
like i basically was like look i can cut
that out
and that's two hours a night that
instead i can create content right
or like when i do the podcast everybody
else at the back when we started this
everybody would go down to the cafeteria
at twitch for lunch
i would walk across the street the
studio was your office was literally
like 50 steps away from
from twitch i would walk 50 steps away
go to the hustle office we would record
from 12 to 1.
everybody else is eating lunch i'm
recording a podcast cool i'll eat lunch
on my desk
like later it doesn't matter right so
there's these little pockets of time you
can unlock
that's the first bit second bit is
hiring i bring on people so when i say
i'm doing x it's rarely just me doing x
it's like
ben or zack or romine or chris or i have
a whole bunch of people that
i say hey i'm doing this interesting
project who wants to do it with me
and they're like i find great people who
want to do interesting things together
and i say cool what's in it for you do
you want money do you want learning do
you want like
rep you don't want to build your network
what do you want out of this i'll make
sure you get it
and they let me like i said be in two
places at once
because i could be doing this and they
could be doing that what's your burn
on all the like because whenever i hear
you say you got all these people i'm
like damn
yeah that must be a lot uh monthly yes
my burn is expensive it's expensive but
the things now bring in money so it's
it's okay it offsets it
but like uh but the angel investing
doesn't bring in money and that's not
angel investing i don't pay salaries
it's
only carry so it's splitting the upside
so they have they they get
they i took some of my my 20 carry and i
took it down
and let them have more carry so um which
you know for them is fine because they
make money doing other things so they're
like cool
this will pay off in five years that's
great and i get to like learn a bunch
about investing
i get to put together a portfolio so if
i want to go get a job doing this or i
want to start my own fund
i'll have a track record to point at and
say no i i did these investments before
i've been doing this for years
so that's kind of like what's in it for
them um so i do have a you know
significant burn i would say it's like
200 to 300 000 a year of like people
cost
do these things my goal is for them to
break even um
but if not like that's what money is for
money is to be invested in things that
will grow
and so i kind of like just look at it
like an investment and uh
it's worked out so far where the side
hustles more than pay for
the money i put in um now the last thing
is basically
an acknowledgement and i talked i was
pretty transparent with the people at
twitch which was like
look i operate not on a nine to five
like
strict schedule like cool i'm just gonna
punch the clock for 40 hours a week no
no
uh i'm here to do this mission you want
this job done
great i'm gonna get that job done here's
the trade i
i can make sure this job gets done you
don't ask me how and when and where and
why and how you know like all the time
uh like not in such a like
confrontational way but like it's an
understood agreement like they know
what i do i'm very open about like hey i
have a podcast i have a
newsletter like the ceo of twitch
subscribes to the newsletter and like
will dm me about it like sometimes right
like
i'm not hiding any of these things they
know i do these things they know they
take some time
but they're okay with that trade because
i deliver the goods in my projects
and so uh my trainer told me this one
day because i told him i said i'm
feeling a little bit guilty like
you know i wonder i really like these
people i don't want them to feel like
i'm shortchanging them he goes well do
you deliver the goods
i was like well yeah like i perform like
they they get the results they want
okay well you're that dude and i was
like what do you mean he's like he's
like they don't pay you to sit in your
chair for certain hours they pay you to
deliver the results
and so uh just make sure you deliver the
results and if you're delivering the
results in less time that's because
you're that dude maybe not everybody
could do that but you could do that
and i was like oh man what a pep talk
that was uh you know made me feel good
about something that i was feeling you
know
uncertain about or uneasy about before
and you're on paternity leave now right
yeah so that helps too yeah exactly
yes and that's you know like big
companies understand like look you
if you have a kid my first kid i only
took 10 days off
which i really regret i should have uh i
should have took the whole leave and so
this time i decided i'd make i'm gonna
make sure i take some off
and this time my family actually really
needs me there whereas the first time i
was like i don't know what the hell i'm
gonna do here
uh my wife's kind of got it under
control let me go back to work
and so this time i kind of realized that
the idea of like oh this project is so
important and like
if i take this time off then you know
let me do it i'll take time off later
and
later never came and that was a big
lesson for me like
don't don't put important things off
till later do them now um
who's the worst person this is such an
interesting question clay bert
uh i bet you i know who that is uh who's
the
worst person you admire
[Laughter]
do you have one for this yeah well like
i it's a great question and it's you can
get in trouble
answering this one um i'm gonna tiptoe a
little bit around it because
it's just weird but i actually love
learning about
dictators um i like i read a ton about
dictators
there's actually a podcast called
dictators so like i like learning about
benito mussolini
i've read a lot about hitler i've read a
lot about fidel castro
um who else um so i think i got in
trouble with this before
because i remember i was in school and i
took a history class and
the question i asked the teacher was
look this sounds so messed up what was
going on back then that sounds totally
screwed up like how did this guy come to
power
and he explained like well here first
you have to understand the state of
germany at the time blah blah blah
he goes the other thing was that like
honestly he i forgot who
hitler's second in command is but he's
like kind of like a famous guy for like
his
almost like his persuasion prowess like
his marketing prowess
yeah uh joseph uh gib uh yes yeah he's
like the head of propaganda he made
movies
exactly i forget his name he's not a
famous guy he's like his number two guys
the head of propaganda exactly and they
did very simple things like everybody
else was putting out like i forgot
like their flyers when they were running
for whatever present whatever their
equivalent of president was was like
all in color so he did everything in
black and white to stand out or if
everyone's black and white he did color
like
he just did a whole bunch of things and
i found it really interesting like oh
oh yeah go gobbles dr goldberg joseph
yeah yeah joseph
yeah yeah yeah yeah so so they had
movies made and they used entertainment
to kind of like get their message across
get the story across they had like
um a whole bunch of like this they
distilled down their philosophy into
these like really catchy
nuggets and so there's all these things
that i thought wow that's like
if you just abstract good and evil away
the skill of accomplishing a very hard
thing which is like getting millions of
people to follow you
there's a lot to be learned from that
and i kind of was like oh that's really
cool and people were like
dude you said hitler's cool like you're
like you're awesome yeah yeah
and that's that's the point i'm getting
at which is like it's so fascinating
that someone
can convince and in my opinion like a
lot of dictators i'm like man if they
like
just like move that early on like
clicked it a few notches to the left and
then that trajectory would have like put
them in a totally different atmosphere
i'm like man it like it but it is
fascinating how someone can come from
nothing and just
create something whether it's an idea a
business a piece of art whatever like i
love that like idea of
manifesting and even though it's
horrible and the worst thing on earth
and i wish they'd it never existed
i always have been fascinated by like a
guy like che guerrera or someone who
like
was just like or uh what's his name
benita mussolini who i just read about
like this wasn't
like supposedly a poor kid and somehow
he convinced all these people
these to do all this horrible horrible
stuff
um and that like to me is fascinating
how he just bent the world around
him and like that's just crazy that hey
people buy into that stuff
and it's crazy that someone that he had
the courage to do that
which sounds like i'm glamorizing these
people i'm not
at all but hopefully you guys understand
the nuance here
and and why it's kind of intriguing yeah
uh
this is two things one um when i met
i've talked a little bit about my friend
vishal the guy who's kind of like a
young guy who i'm like this guy's
definitely gonna be a billionaire and
he's also kind of like
totally hell-bent on becoming a
billionaire and he lets every part of
his other life go like
what we were talking about earlier where
i was like well on the podcast i talked
a lot about business and money but like
in my real life i'm doing i'm really
actually more passionate about these
other things i
spend more time on he's the opposite
whatever he talks about here he's 10
times more obsessed with it outside of
this
and i love him for that and i remember
when i met him he was he he was like
send me this documentary about like
this like warlord in africa who just
like just like they get like the
absolute like
gang gangster [__] this guy did he's
like i love this movie i love this guy
i was like oh it's kind of like heinous
crimes you know he's like oh no it's
crazy
they told me the story about this guy
who became the emperor of china
and he started off like as a like an
orphan
like servant and then ended up by the
end of his lifetime as the emperor of
china i forgot his name but like
one of the ancient emperors of china was
like started off as an orphan boy with
not a dollar to his name and then like
rule i mean it sounds like uh genghis
khan or something
yeah and he was like and like not just
like got there like it's not just a hero
story like he also like
you know like slayed his enemies and
like enslaved people or i don't know
what he did but like
it wasn't all you know just like
underdog you know it wasn't just david
and goliath
and he told me that story and i was like
you're a maniac
but um you know i actually would love to
invest in you because that's the kind of
like maniac you want being a founder of
these companies
like somebody who is wired a little bit
differently and uh as i remember hearing
that but anyways
the phrase you say that's like every
great man is also a bad man
yeah that's kind of true everybody i
like my favorite comedian is louis ck
who i believe is currently canceled for
you know like doing something gross in
front of a bunch of women or whatever
you know like
and i don't think that's cool but i love
louis ck and i still love louis c.k
and like i think he's awesome um as a
comedian i didn't say he's an awesome
character you know that's an awesome
human being and i want to be like him no
i think he's an amazing comedian
and i love his comedy um conor mcgregor
you know i had a poster behind me of him
you know painting that i had made of him
behind me for half these podcasts he's
been accused of sexual assault he's been
you know
he people say he's on drugs and he's
kind of a [__] and like
other things too he's an amazing fighter
and i love his drive of how he went from
like a
plumber on welfare to the wealthiest
fighter of all time and he said the
whole time from the very beginning
that's what it's going to be
he called it and there's videos of him
when he's alone in his bedroom
not even a professional yet and he says
i'm going to be the greatest and here's
what i'm going to do i'm going to do xyz
and he did it all
i admire that but i also think he does a
bunch of scumbag [__]
and like i'm okay with that trade you
know so there's like a bunch of people
that are like that
i was traveling me and sarah one time
were driving by uh chick-fil-a
and we were like i want to get that do
you want that and she was like yeah i
want that so bad and we were and she was
like but do we want to support them
uh this was right when they like did
some stuff uh
anti-tank marriage yeah and uh
we were like well my taste buds don't
really
know if you're homophobic so
i think we'd be it's okay i think we
could like the chicken but also
or it was something maybe we were at
some place and they had the chicken
there and i was like i don't think my
taste buds
could tell if you're homophobic or not
so we could probably eat it
um all right let's answer a video
question a lot lately i've been thinking
about
trying to hire my friends as operators
of sorts
and i'm just worried about like damaging
that relationship
like i think it's an awesome idea being
able to choose who i work with
i'm just concerned that all that
friendship could uh
go away when there's something as
important as like business
and money involved um i have a pretty
strong opinion on that which is
no i think you actually shouldn't in
most cases
don't do it in some cases it makes sense
but in most cases i actually think it's
a bad idea
and i also have myself failed at doing
this a little bit but i actually don't
think you should be friends with your
co-worker or your friends with your
employees if you're a manager you
shouldn't be friends with your employees
if you're a business owner or ceo i
actually don't think i think you should
be friendly but i think you should be
really careful about being friends with
your employees
um and so my opinion is no i also think
that like
you probably disagree sean or maybe you
do but like even if they're if you're
worth your co-workers
and anytime in the evening and alcohol
shows up
i think you should leave i don't even
think you should be in the same room
um so i'm pretty strict about that
although i am friends with a lot of my
co-workers so i don't exactly follow all
this but
i i think that i'll might regret some of
that we're opposites on this
so uh you know what's funny i always try
to be friends with my employees
and i feel like they don't want to be
friends with me so i'm like yeah i'm
like yeah i'm trying to be friends with
them and then i'm like oh that's weird
you guys all got together that saturday
and like
oh yeah i was just at home coulda could
it come yeah
well what's funny is like when you like
start a business and you work a lot like
you don't really have that many friends
like i'm friends with you and jack and
ramon and like four
i've got like four friends but my
co-workers are like
i'm like will you guys be my friends i'm
with you all the time and i don't get
invited to anything either yeah so i i
realized pretty quickly uh they don't
want me around
uh and i was like but it's weird i'm
such a good guy and so anyways
that part didn't work not because i i
didn't intentionally try not to be
friends with them they just
didn't be friends with me back that's
okay the main thing for for me on the
hiring side
is um i would say hire your competent
friends
so um my very first business i started i
started with two of my best buddies from
college
and we were just like yeah we're gonna
do this ah we you know well there's no
ceo there's no hierarchy here we'll all
just make decisions together we'll all
split the equity perfectly equally
we didn't really like put too much
thought into it because we were just
like 21 year old kids didn't really know
much about anything
and like fast forward a year later we
had to have like a very uncomfortable
conversation with one of the guys which
was like hey dude like i feel like
you're not pulling your weight and he
was trying but like we were just like
you're kind of just doing this part and
like we feel like we're doing these
other eight parts
and in retrospect i don't even know if
that was really true but it definitely
was an uncomfortable conversation and i
could see the downside of it
but what i would say is like the the
saving grace for me has always been
i only have hired my competent friends
and competent friends do two things one
is they perform
so you don't have this you're not just
hiring a buddy because you're your buddy
you're hiring this person because
they're good but you only know them
because they're your buddy
the second thing is they are reasonable
and they will unders
they will understand if you're really
clear up front about like
look here's the dynamic like we're
buddies but
sometimes i'm gonna have to tell you if
i feel like the job's not getting done
and i actually i want you to tell me too
if you think that's true like
are we okay if it's gonna be kind of
uncomfortable like we're not just gonna
be able to just shoot the [__] like we
gotta also have these two modes that we
can operate in
and i wanna make sure like you're on
board with that so i'm i think with it
with a little bit of good communication
up front
you can get the big benefit which is
it's way more fun to do stuff with
friends
like companies are hard they take a long
time it's like a really long road trip
and you want to be in the car with
people you really like and so whether
those were
new people who you just happen to enjoy
great or they're people you already
enjoyed who you invite into the car
because they're your buddy and you want
to do this company with them i think
when it works
when you do it with your friends it's
the best and uh
when it doesn't work it's even worse
than if they were they were not your
friends so you got to take the good with
the bad
but um we had a podcast with this guy on
this feed called mike brown who you
introduced me to him i met him at your
office
yeah he had a successful business then
he brought both of his brothers on board
and i was like why did you do that let
most people say you know don't do
business with family it gets messy he's
like
these are my brothers i love these guys
i want to see them every day
i want to hang out with them i want to
win together i want us all to win
he's like i if he's like i feel blessed
that i got to set this up
where i get to do business with my best
friends and i was like
well when you say it like that like what
the hell am i thinking about that's
obvious said that sounds great and so i
think there are
downsides but i'm of the mindset of if
you pick competent people you won't
regret it
um all right we'll do a couple more fast
questions someone asked who could squat
more weight i think
i think me sure that's definitely you i
have uh i have osgood slaughters in my
knees
if you if you have it you know if you
don't have it you don't know but because
of that i don't squat i can't
i never squatted my whole life because
uh of that issue
um okay this is a deep one it's cool
we'll answer it what are your biggest
insecurities uh both what are the
biggest insecurities both of you
struggle with
uh i'll say i'll go first sometimes i'm
i get incredibly insecure
that anything i make won't be good
enough because i move too fast
and i just do surface level [__] and i
don't treat it like a crafts like a
craftsman
enough and i don't like think things
through
i get pretty self-conscious when i meet
really smart people who i meet a ton of
them through this
job i'm like oh my god this person's iq
is just like they're so much smarter
than me i just cannot keep up
like because uh so i i'm insecure about
that i'm insecure
um that i um like i didn't go to
stanford or like a fancy school
and when i meet people in the in crowd
like when we meet guys like andrew chen
who
who who works in andreessen horowitz i'm
like dude
like i kind of want to be in the in
crowd but like i don't want to work that
hard to do it and i just don't care that
much but i wish i did
i feel a little insecure about that um
um and i feel uh i get insecure
because i'm pretty loud and that
sometimes makes people not take me as
seriously as i think they should so
those are mine
those are really good ones and i think
very relatable
probably for most people um mine i would
say
i don't even know if there's insecurity
as much as like because when people say
insecurity it's usually like
what's something you worry about but
it's not really true but you kind of
worry too much about it
i think mine like is true it's more like
here's your weakness
here's your you know your um your
weakness or your flaw i
would say like and something i i kind of
worry about which is
i don't really filter myself um and
i so i just talk a lot and i don't
really think about it before i do it i
don't really think
i don't even filter myself with actions
like like i said with a rolling phone i
was like oh that's cool let's do it
can we do it today let's do it now i
don't want to think things through and
so
um i would say the fear i have and the
insecurity i have is around
actually like hurting people's feelings
like sometimes i could say stuff that's
inconsiderate or
um or hurtful in some way or like
you know too opinionated and no
nobody asks for your [__] opinion
type of thing um so i i'm kind of
conscious of that like i would say i'm
pretty self
self-conscious about that that's the
word not insecure i'm self-conscious
that
while i do that and i don't really like
that part of me that like
i will say things and do things that i
don't really think about how that
how other how others will feel about it
and
um and also like when i meet people like
our friend ramon who's so considerate
i just feel so inconsiderate in
comparison and i'm like oh i want to be
that way
but man i'm like the opposite and like
you know i'm like
i'm like a knuckle dragger i'm just like
yeah a neanderthal
so i feel really bad about that and then
i would say like the other minor
insecurity
is like am i just wasting my talents
like so when i meet people who are doing
really amazing things like
scott harrison you know he's been on a
15-year mission to bring clean drinking
water to the world
i went with him to africa and we went to
a town where they had installed one of
the
water wells and literally the town was
like it was like a parade that scott was
here
they literally thought this guy was
jesus and uh he kind of like looked like
jesus in the moment i thought he was
jesus at the moment
and like he's totally humble he hated
that they were celebrating him he was
there
like not for that reason but um that's
the reality of the impact of his work is
he literally changes like
the lives of entire like towns
essentially in africa
and um and so then when i see that i'm
like what am i wasting
do i need to do this silly e-commerce
thing do i need to do this
newsletter who gives a [__] you know and
so sometimes i feel really small
about the way i decided to use my time
and my talents
i completely agree with that compared to
other people um
last question uh when are you guys gonna
do
since covet is pretty much in the past
when
is the next meetup going to happen i'm
actually doing a meet so i'm driving to
st
louis to spend a week with my family
there and i'm stopping in oklahoma city
because that was just like the middle
ground
and i tweeted out so i've got like 30 or
40 or 50 people i forget how many people
rsvp'd
for a breakfast in oklahoma city and if
you're down sean although you just had a
baby so
uh imagine we're going to wait a little
while i would totally be down
of doing like a two-week tour or
something where we go from place to
place to place i don't know if we could
drive i don't know what you'd want to do
but i'm totally down like a two-week
thing
yes totally agree i think like if we
just said all right this fall
we're gonna go on tour we're gonna go to
these seven cities seven cities in seven
days or seven cities in ten days or
something like that
and we just like set up the events i
would love to do that
uh i think that would be amazing we just
hired a community manager her name's
april
um and she set this event up for me i
just said hey i'm going to show up in
oklahoma city can you get like can you
book me a hotel
and uh set up like an eventbrite and
i'll tweet it out and um
well we can have her do that and help
help us you
uh do something really great that i
think you should tell people which is
when you you hosted events but you make
the themes
great so like you used to do this thing
called pizza and 40s
um so can you give me i don't even know
what other ones you've done but like
tell the people of some of the different
events you've done because i think it's
really smart
when you set those events up people want
to come and
yeah they behave differently because of
the theme
of how you set up because i've been to a
lot of silicon valley networking events
are boring as [__]
you don't want to go and when people go
they're all like surface level
level like they you know it's not a fun
place to be they don't let their
guard down your events are very
different so can you what are some of
the different themes you've come up with
and like
do you have a theory on why that works
no
i don't have a theory i just think it's
fun uh i do it for the what i said
earlier in the episode i it just because
it's cool that's the only reason why
so i do the anti-mba that's a book club
where we get an expert to come in and
discuss the book's topic
um i've done this sounds douchey to say
but like i don't even drink
so that's why it's funny but we have
this thing called pizza and 40s
so the speaker gets a 40-ounce beer
because a 40-ounce beer takes like an
hour to drink
and as and so we only would have pizza
because we were poor and that's all we
could afford and we would give the
speaker a 40-ounce beer
they've got to drink the beer and when
the beer's done the talk's done and the
answers get a little bit wilder as they
get deeper into the beer
we did 2x which was focused on women
telling their story it stands for 2x
chromosomes
um we had like did you go to the one
that we had in the marina
no what's that um we used to do 2x at
this thing called palace of fine arts
and we had like literally 2 000 women
there
in san francisco it probably was like
the largest contingency of like
uh uh tech women probably in the world
or in the country it was kind of
interesting
um so we did that what else do we do
hustle con con con
uh which is con con is the startup
that's
the content conference i thought com con
was a funny name what else
uh anything else have you do i feel like
you've done some breakfast thing before
have you done a breakfast thing
rise and grind yeah we did rise and
grind um which was we were talking about
different stuff in the morning over and
like a grind like coffee like
coffee but also like working hard you're
good at this you're good at coming up
with kind of a catchy name and a catchy
theme for people to get behind uh and
the vibe is very different so i think
that's
if somebody's doing it like that doesn't
take any extra money
it just takes like a little creativity
and like you've
made your thing better and cooler more
fun for you to do more fun for people to
come to more fun for speakers to attend
because it's different than the average
thing so
long story short uh maybe late summer if
you're down
yeah i'm definitely down all right great
that's it we'll do it
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what
travel never looking back
[Music]
uh